when I was 14 my family and I moved over
5,000 miles from Milan to Seoul Manasa
last night in Italy I remember feeling
devastated because the world as I knew
it had been taken away from me my
international school in LAN was a
diverse environment that fostered
individuality I took French and
journalism as electives I played soccer
after school and went canoeing in France
as a part of a school field trip but in
my all-female school in Korea I was
stuck in school from 7:30 a.m. to 10:00
p.m.
everyone took the exact same courses and
there was no such thing as electives I
went from being the math and science
whiz in Italy to flunking my very first
science assignment in Korea we had to
write the 118 elements of the periodic
table 60 times each now that's over
7,000 times the next day I proudly
presented my homework the teacher
glanced at it and wrote a big X
apparently it had to be written
horizontally and not vertically which
meant that I flunked the assignment and
had to do it all over again the next day
you see it was quite a rough transition
but by the end of high school I felt
like I'd fully adjusted to life in Korea
I'd made a few good friends and pulled
many many all-nighters to catch it to
school work and I remember thinking the
toughest days of my life are finally
over but to my surprise there were
significant and challenging life
transitions over over and over again
including coping with a big heartbreak
moving to Japan and then Tong Kong
starting work and coming here to the GSB
and I recognized there was a pattern
when I first step in two seasons of
change I often felt like I'd lost
control like I had lost a part of myself
and I confess this is how I felt many
times during my first year of the GSB as
I started what was supposed to be the
two best years of my life I wondered why
I didn't feel as confident and as happy
as many of you seem to be can anyone
relate to that so I asked 107 mbit/s of
the class of 2016
what were your dominant feeling most
dominant feelings as you spent your
first year the results were I openin
most 60% of you said that you were
primarily anxious in your first year 45%
said that you were excited which is
great 43% said that you felt like you
had lost control and 38% said that you
felt lonely and only 7% felt like you
are confident now the feelings of
anxiety or the lack of control seem like
a common experience as we go through
seasons of change and I realize we have
full agency to shape and manage this
transition instead of reluctantly or
reactively struggling through them so
today I want to share with you the art
of managing life transitions and I've
packaged in them in 3 R's recalibrate
your frame and reach out the first R is
recalibrate your expectations I lived
and worked in 9 different countries in
my life so I thought coming here tonight
the United States as a student would be
a piece of cake I expected to hit the
ground running on day 1 but as my
feelings deviated from my expectations
of how quickly I could adjust I felt
increasingly nervous and perhaps this is
why the survey shows that the students
have lived in the United States for long
period work
Porcia li more anxious than the students
who came here for the first time
whereas international students expected
coming to the GSB to be a big life
transition and expected to feel
frustrated even many of the American
students didn't think that this really
big change but the fact that it was made
many of us feel nervous I realized last
year that I was penalizing myself for
falling short of an unrealistic
expectation I was putting on myself once
I started recalibrating these
expectations I created more room for
self mercy and with that came a newfound
sense of relief and calmness that helped
me push through this time of transition
so if you're going through a transition
or the next time you go through one
think hard about the types of
expectations you're putting on yourself
and recalibrate them and always remember
to have more self mercy and not less the
second R is reframe challenging times
and transitions as an opportunity to
grow when I first started work in
consulting in Korea my manager had given
me some rough feedback my confidence had
hit rock bottom and I did what most
first-year analysts did at the time
which is go to the bathroom and cry and
my senior analyst Meredith came to find
me in the restroom and there I was
crying and she said something that I
will never forget
she said Kristine things are hard
because you're growing yes it's
uncomfortable and yes it's painful but
only because you're taking on bigger
things in life Stanford psychologist
Carol Dweck calls this the growth
mindset and found that this is exactly
what allows people to thrive even during
the most difficult life situations
so if you are going through a season of
change and if you have all these
negative feelings hitting you remember
that you have the agency to reframe your
mindset because when you do and if you
do you will come out of life transitions
stronger I've experienced this many
times in my life and our classmates have
done to the biggest single biggest shift
in emotions from the first year the
second year was confidence whereas only
7% of our classmates felt confident in
the first year 50% said that they felt
confident their second year and this was
the second most dominant feeling after
gratitude so always remember to reframe
your mindset and it's in your agency to
do so the third R is reach out what
amplified my feelings of anxiety and
loss of control with the perception that
I was the only one feeling this way and
I didn't want to share this with a lot
of you because I'm usually a happy
person and I didn't want to be perceived
in any other way a breakthrough moment
for me came when I was talking to a
close a group of friends and I confided
my true feelings with them and to my
surprise even the most confident looking
one was struggling inside the
realization that I am NOT alone gave me
so much relief and this the sense of
togetherness helped me heal out of my
anxieties so if you're like me reach out
to someone it's okay to be vulnerable
and on the flip side if you know someone
who's going through a significant change
reach out to them because you never know
how much of an impact you can have in
their lives
so here are the three hours of managing
life transitions recalibrate reframe and
reach out whether you have another year
of school left or you're going out into
the real world
take this toolkit with you and always
remember that you have full agency to
shape manage the many many life
transitions that are coming your way
thank you